very clearly what I want okay now as as  you said probably I'm not available so I  don't gonna get what I want cool I stay  by my horn I don't need a man like oh I  get what I want I guess I can just say  buy my own I don't need a man I know the  other child I'm like a person I'm not a  baby machine I'm not uh you know what I  mean like that's my value  for what you're saying you don't sound  very happy about that I just thought I'd  I'm not very happy about how another  other women can think about our body and  our Essence  I didn't I'm telling you what men want  yeah but you can you can think in your  way and that's that's perfect  I've talked to thousands of men yeah